butchered dogs from sale in Ulan South
China on public display but not meant
for wider public view this footage was
provided to Sky News by activists on the
ground ahead of the annual dog meat
festival which starts this Sunday the
pandemic has put the spotlight on
unusual meat and unsanitary market
conditions in China the slaughter
butchery and sale of dogs isn't just
upsetting to many inside China and
globally it's also risky we understand
that and often is caused by a huge
concentration of animals of different
species and will suffer compromise the
immunity system a lot of thoughts are
such animals in great concentration and
with huge psychological and meant a
pistol problem the dog meat is the
dental cream gone for pandemic the
festival has been running since at least
2010 these pictures are from 2015 and
2016 when it was all much more public
but as a result of the pandemic the
Chinese government banned trade in wild
animals and it's also issued guidelines
that dogs should be classified as
companions not livestock to cities
Schengen and too high
both in the southern province of
Guangdong this year banned the sale of
table meat entirely but restaurants
specializing in dog meat are still
operating in Ulan in the neighboring
province of quan chi
even if trade is less brisk and before
the vast majority of Chinese people do
not eat dogs in the cosmopolitan capital
of Beijing it's hard to find anyone who
approves yet somewhat better thoughtful
- [ __ ] wanna know what you're not young
dinoworld
where's your true God this isn't like
you didn't see a hard world sure run for
those the voucher good
fun who was it
poor Beijing says doesn't always go
especially in the provinces the Ministry
of Agriculture here in the capital has
issued new guidelines but they are just
guidelines they're not a new law for all
the mites of the party for all that
public opinion might be against the dog
meat trade change is still slow without
a law limited direct intervention
provides the only hope
activists bought these puppies to save
them from the slaughter ten were rescued
the hope is to find them homes in the UK
despite all the cruelty and all the
risks of novel disease the dog meat
trade continues Tom Cheshire Sky News
Beijing